et en forêt garot auéo malétin on estime
qu'ils sont responsables de 10 % des
feux de forêt dans dans le monde un
risque réel puisqu'en France euh c'est
le de c'est le 19e pays le plus
consommateur de tabac au monde avec 31,8
% de fumeurs en 2022 une très mauvaise
habitude dont on a du mal à se défaire
et que les jeunes qui en sont témoins au
quotidien peuvent reproduire en
grandissant neuf villes d'indrloire ont
donc décidé de mettre en place des
espaces sans tabac devant des lieux
publics fréquenté par les enfants alors
est-ce que ça marche Aurélie Renault
s'est rendue à Ligueil 4 ans après leur
mise en
place au-delà de la ligne blanche c'est
zéro cigarette nous sommes en décembre
2019 et près de l'école maternelle de
Ligueil l'objectif est de montrer
l'exemple aux enfants en ne fumant pas
et c'est Axel CAN en personne qui venait
inaugurer cet espace sans fumer ni Mo
avant cela il était devenu difficile
pour les enseignants et le personnel de
l'école d'expliquer aux parents que la
cigarette nétait était pas la bienvenue
nous revenons à Ligueil les parents
ont-ils vraiment pris l'habitude de ne
plus fumer en attendant leurs enfants la
question est posée à Monsieur le Maire
nous dans ce secteur de l'enfance on ne
fume plus et j'ai constaté que non
seulement ne fumait plus dans la zone
marquée au sol mais on ne fume plus
avant non plus c'està qu'on a pris
l'habitude quand on est avec les enfants
on les éduque aussi pour leur faire
comprendre ce qu''est la santé et depuis
quelques temps l'école bénéficie d'une
nouvelle entrée et le maire tente un
pari a-t-on vraiment besoin de panneaux
d'interdiction et a-t-on besoin vraiment
de nouvelles frontières au sol ma
réponse est non la bonne habitude qui a
été prise à la première entrée doit être
reportée sur la seconde Paris gagné pas
de MO au sol l'habitude a été prise pour
mettre en place des espaces sans tabac
les collectivités peuvent être
accompagné par la Ligue contre le cancer
qui fournit gratuitement la
signalétiique et propose des animations
on vient dans l'école avec des bénévoles
qui sont formés à la thématique et nos
outils pour parler avec les enfants des
dangers du tabac de de travailler leurs
compétences psychosociales pour savoir
comment on peut dire non au tabac voilà
en France le tabac est responsable de
45000 cancers par an l'objectif des
espaces sans tabac est simple
dénormaliser la cigarette c'est faire
penser aux gens que le comportement
normal c'est de pas fumer on l'a fait
pour fumer à l'intérieur plus personne
ne fume à l'intérieur ni d'un café ni
même chez soi on va dehors on ouvre la
fenêtre et bien c'est la même chose dans
certains lieux donc on pense autour des
des écoles mais aussi dans les parcs
publics dans les jardins tout ça c'est
des lieux où il serait normal de ne pas
fumer et c'est un petit peu l'objectif
de ces espaces sans tabac c'est de faire
de matérialiser le fait que il est
normal de ne pas fumer dans ces
endroitsl en indrloire il existe
aujourd'hui 35 espaces sans
tabac